I am setting out to do a 30-day throws
challenge and I propose you do it with
me I'm setting the goal of practicing
throws everyday for at least five
minutes and that might not sound like a
lot but it's based on a theory that I've
read about the most successful goals and
changing behavior are process goals that
are easy to do so for instance if you
wanted to get more fit running the goals
people tend to fail at is making goal
like I am in 60 days I'm gonna be
running 10 kilometers every day most
people end up not running at all if they
take that kind of goal but if I set the
goal I'm gonna put my shoes on five
times a week and get at least to the
corner of the block often 60 days later
they are running 10 kilometers a day so
many times I've started throats and then
I never get very far so I'm setting this
goal to stick with it longer than I
usually do I will make some videos on
some very basic ideas like how to do you
know a no beat throw or a half circle
throw so I propose we also build our
favorite people to watch because
obviously there's some amazing pie
artists putting out lots of good
material it would be awesome if some of
you made your own videos of the things
you'll be working on and then 30 days so
I don't know August let's say August
20th fish we can post videos on the
progress we've made after having spent
30 days practicing at least five minutes
a day
throws challenge Henchy